One more thing before we get back
to computational computer vision.
When we talk about
the color space of devices
actually when we talk about the color
space of devices, what we're usually
talking about is what's referred
to as the color gamut, okay?
And color gamuts are just
subsets of possible colors.
And here I'm showing you
three different color gamuts
that have been measured or that
are just defined in a particular way.
So you see this first one?
Alright, this is the 1931, that's that
Chromaticity Diagram I was telling you
about, and the, and this big
that's all the colors you can see.
Notice that on the inside,
is this triangle that is
a tremendous subset of that possible
set and you see it says HDTV.
Turns out these are all
the colors that HDTV can make.
So if you wanted to make this
really nice lush deep green,
HDTV can't do it because of the way
it defines its color space.
All right?
Any photographers out there?
I hope so.
If you use Photoshop or any other
photographic manipulations systems
that understand color spaces, they'll
tell you that you can have it in a color
space of sRGB or
Adobe RGB or ProPhoto RGB.
These are different sized color spaces,
and
you know one of them is
really small it's this sRGB.
Okay, why do people use that one so
much?
That's the color space that most color
monitors used to be able to support.
Okay.
And so,
if you were displaying something,
say on the web,
you don't want to have these colors out
here because they're not going to
show up the right way on a monitor.
So when you try to do color balancing
sometimes you have to map colors that
are distributed out throughout all of
color space onto a smaller color space.
That's particularly true
when you print things.
Here is a, some gamut comparisons of so
again the, the big one
is all of human vision, the white one is
this Adobe RGB we were talking about.
Notice the green one.
The green one it says
Epson 2200 Premium Luster.
That's the color gamut of one particular
printer on one particular paper, okay.
That's the set of colors
that that printer can make.
So if you have a color out
here it won't work very well.
Likewise down there.
I learned this the hard way when I
first got into digital photography.
My daughter at the time was about 11
years old was wearing this really kind
of dark blue shiny, royal blue dress and
I printed it on a HP printer,
not a great printer but not
a terrible printer and it was purple.
And what was annoying to me
to begin with is the color of
a bunch of other things were perfect.
So why, you know, because I understood
color balance, you know, maybe I had
a wrong color, no, you know, my,
my son's gray thing was nice and gray.
It didn't, it didn't shift blue or red.
But her pur,
her blue thing was looking purple.
The reason was is that is was outside
the color gamut of the printer.
All right?
And I've subsequently paid a lot of
money to get a much better printer